they have a history with prime ministers
in this part of the world but just like
everywhere else the talk is of what the
next one will do about the issues
causing a creeping anxiety it was
different when their MP was pm and
brought world leaders to the pub and in
truth Liz truss's big moment past the
lunchtime Crowd by at the Dunn cow in
not that they don't care here I don't
think it's gonna she's got to be any
good for the working class
I think it's going to be a nice South
divide even more so than it was and I
fear I saw fear for the NHS I feel for
the people that are living from day to
day and I worry about the gas and
electricity are really worried
three years ago a Victorious Boris
Johnson came to pull a pint at the
Cricket Club to celebrate the Tories
demolishing the blue wall of one's safe
labor seats like this one the local
newspaper front page back then reflected
that Tory tidal wave across the north
today's tells a very different story the
business Community here in the north
calling on Liz truss to deliver what
Boris Johnson promised here three years
ago to prevent what they say is a coming
disaster for communities like this
it's already arrived for some this
community Project's been forced to close
because of spiraling costs the
communities are all struggling and it's
it's real life this is what
is what ground now and it's founder
hardly reassured by the change in number
10. she said already that she's going
she's going to take a week to come out
with what she thinks is her plan that
concerns me because there's a lot of
people who need that information sooner
businesses have closed too those
surviving like Betty's Boudoir say they
have to have hope we're in a a state of
not knowing what's going to happen over
the winter time and everything
everybody's worried everybody's
concerned and we can feel that with
business I do like the idea that she's a
lady and that that's good good for us
women but
um I just hope she's strong enough to
cope with a job
they've seen Prime Ministers come and go
here but rarely has this community so
many communities felt so vulnerable and
so in need of some certainty Greg Milam
Sky News Sedgefield